hi everyone we watch little more color
click more minutes chips at time people
to ride it's my great pleasure to talk
to you and know what to really thank for
all the organizing team it's relating to
be able to speak to you now from
actually from France soak a poor start
so hi everyone it's my great pleasure to
talk to you that today about our mainly
about our net diary project and how it
started and it's truly a work that will
be experimenting going from bedside to
bench and eventually back it all started
about with ms genetics which is
something that I'll rude and bathed in
San Francisco I've been really really
involved with so I'm myself a faculty
from the department of neurology at
university of california san francisco
and i want to disclose that I've been
founder of metadata glove comp company
we both biostatistics in as a service in
2008 another fan drew nearer medicine
USA last year which is offering
personalized medicine and development so
let's go around
just going to show you the slides and
we'll talk about this in as bios screen
project which essentially is an ipad
application so really the best what I do
who is actually doing a 90 now that's
really the best for this is that this is
prototype for real and so instead of
that but flow do today is really kind of
a video that we prepared showing what it
is what it is about the bios screen is
really a project from the entire to of
people that you can see here on as it
was a background of great building and
the mission bay campus south of san
francisco with you on the bay area it
has it has really been preceded by a
team of people that have been really
helping so a core a coating of people
and that really have been working with
us on the most this technical part of of
the context but also great extremely so
here what i want to show so from great
team of people the coroner style screen
team wins a lot of ground of skinny old
and tender data organization data
analysis in clinical data and those who
the
tribution of them a dozen of key faculty
from the UCSF and a center and
investigator or MS a big cohort so let
me just tell you a little bit of that
and ask since it's about it's all about
a nice in this session and and maybe
also the live we have on from ms you are
affecting about half million people in
north america cheap on 1 2.3 million
people worldwide and truly the leading
cause of disability among young adults
and really what I think it's very
important is what it means to a to a
patient the initial symptoms are there
at age 20 to 14 it's a large lonely
scenes that you have to live with for a
very long period of time but with
parenthesis of progressing in disability
there's no cure there's easy buddy Frank
treatments but these treatments are very
expensive and more importantly I think
we don't really realize what it means to
patients but patients are totally in the
dark about the progression and you think
about it it's extremely it's extremely
difficult you have a disease where you
don't really understand what you have a
mess even if we know that genetic
factors are very important and this is
very important to remember that it's not
like an infectious disease where you're
going to say well at that time I was
infected by a virus or something and
more importantly was once you know you
had a mess we know nothing about the
future you can even we don't really know
about how it's going to progress and
including this very very large
variability from one patient to the next
so ms it's very interesting because it's
it's really challenging challenging
things with very complex technical
season beginning at the rating ms is
very complex because you have to
integrate a lot of different variables
and factors it's truly a lot factory or
disease with the interplay of genetics
environment this melody knowledge
permanent manifestation and as i said
earlier a lot of variability all the
time for a given patient and also across
the across the patient of it so 1 is
equal to Wed is more and more important
in earnest is really treating the right
treatments so many remaining our know
few years ago there was not so much tomb
in town too many treatment to think
about and now we really have many
different to every captions now each of
them has different efficacy profile and
also different risk profile and not that
music to say what is the what is we look
on a date the recommended guidance is
preferred wall so what's happened is
really kind of try and try and try or
narrow process it is pretty common in ms
and to try to find the safest drug with
the maximum efficacy for a bit impatient
the question really had with this
project we're really thinking about how
can we think about integrating all the
information you have all this different
factory the very important for mass
whether they are coming from analyze the
results of clinical trial genetics etc
etc and let's hope you start thinking
about the initial screen project as an
integrative platform that will be able
to take into account all the information
but before before i'm showing that to
you i want to step back and tell you a
little bit
about the origin of this project because
America's in very strong in genetics and
beans are those limited groups in the
world with in founding the international
ms genetic consultant in front leading
very very successful in advancing the
understanding we have of canals from and
Anna susceptibility for Lucinda genetic
policy so award opportunity i give you
an overview of a very summery of dream
of working say about ms and and the best
to you that is really to have an
historical perspective so I I like to
present the genetic of the mass by
looking at really the one result we have
we had for that moment for two years now
it's really the finding that there's
some genetic polymorphisms in the LHC
region that our associated with the
nests accessibility and for 30 years
that was the only in genetic marker that
was known to be associated with ms risk
many others were were tested and until
two thousand seven when there was the
very beginning of the genome-wide
Association era and by looking at at
using multiple genes had an experimental
information we were able to finally
discover you mean our a new genetic
marker and
including the APD I also a receptacle
model that has been since that 2007 one
of the most important gene associated is
ms outside edge of the other engines as
you can hear are nearby Leo's people
here in not in the west of France and
I've called right for for hearing how
all that noise in background so since
2007 in with this Jewess you are really
change of understory understanding of
the mask and in particular outside the
MHC we found many additional genes so
mainly need 60 new 2010 62 in 2012 and a
few months as a global coalition another
name nitrogen and paper where the number
of low low low side that are associated
with ms risk is about 110 so if if if
that looks extremely successful and
because we have we went from one to
regina me 2007 to 110 in 2014 the other
part that is very important is really
truly get the not only not virgins but
the complexity of the amount of the
knowledge we would to think about our
genetic associations and that's
typically the case for the H Lane that's
true that we have we had only more in
region 4 for a very long period of time
but the mobile that explain the MS risk
actually became extremely complex
suffered over the years and and they are
extremely difficult to understand and
now because we need haplotypes and be
pro types which are way too prepared on
how to type properly describe the
genetic risk in that but for ujin the
reason I'm saying that is that is the
genetic was a typical problem in in ms
say hey we went from
there was well known and indeed to
remember easy to understand to a gene
which require more and more complexity
to detail and to understand the type of
association with multiple sclerosis and
the same is actually currently up now
happening outside there make sure when
more than one jet market is wounded to
describe the risk in a particular region
so it's a really a quantitative change
than member of markers and it's also
qualitative change because the
complexity of the model that we evolving
overall it's a very interesting tree in
to remember in the clean or not on paper
we showed that the violence that it
explained I DMHC here actually just
about one third to half of what we're
able to explain using the rest of the
team so more than 100 more custom on one
hand one region on the other emh see
that still explained about of the risk
the reason why i'm anton i was i would
show you that before talking about the
bank screen you see because back in
2010-2011 or group we say hey something
is very much changing when you look at
what happened here around to 2011 2010
we stopped you had and more deadly
marker that we can remember this is
really an illustration of how complex on
this narrow silence never genetics and
biomedicine generals becoming because we
have the g pro Juma's and all these
associations we were able to discover a
great deal of knowledge in genetics
jessica ballots what we're doing is in
this genome-wide Association analysis
we're taking thousands of patients it
taking a thousand of control with taking
hundreds of thousands are various
marker the single nucleotide
polymorphism and we're comparing the
cases to the control and using a bunch
of statistical methods to make sure that
we truly have a little bit of excess of
one particular module in cases versus in
control in ms in people with advanced
compared to people without a less and
then words very successful because we
know having 110 genes that we know for
sure have something related to a less
risk but let's create really a problem
because even if you're great geneticists
and very much in vogue you can't
remember all these genes and it's also a
little frustrating because all this us
is really unnatural of comparing
thousands of cases and thousands of
patients has enough patience and seismic
controls and you know the next step is
just to get bigger and we'll find more
jeans great but that's also created a
new opportunity to actually say hey
instead of looking at thousands of
patients for and thousands of controls
for one marker maybe we can look for a
great number of marker in one individual
and see how much of these markers of
these risk aliens are actually
accumulated in one single individual and
that's where we started to design method
as many others called genetic risk or
genetic risk profile were unlike in the
jewish when you are the population metal
you can go back to the individual go
back to the bedside and start to have a
profile of an individual patient and
you'll take H lady are worn and smooth
the risk areas president I'll take the
next one hour seven receptor is called
in 2007 and we'll see if the markers
present and you can take the other ones
in etc etc and now we're doing that for
one tangent so we know we're now able to
go back from the research
population-based analysis that G works
comparing the thousands of patients to
an individual level of analysis where we
can
arise in a mathematical score at will
automatically be multiple sclerosis
genetic burden we can still arise so
much one the particular patient
accumulate lot of lots of genetic
markers so that that's really important
because again what we need is really to
to follow to catch up in a way where's
for the literature that that study means
some genetic signaled for sclerosis and
again I'm taking that as an example of
how much the knowledge is growing and
how much we need to have access to
information at the individual level so
we usually describe the knowledge of
that ms genetics into the ocean amusing
a versioning system pre-2007 on the HLA
and with the first Jiro's and we had
like a version warm around 2010 with 16
snips a version 2 of the neural
engineering schematics with 62 slips and
the passion 3d was 110 which is almost a
recent one but sure a versatile for is
also coming and we are really working on
that so we summarize and explain that in
a reviewing logical reviews and also
show that these markers are extremely
diverse in terms of frequency and also
where corporations of naming the ethics
eyes and their contribution to Allah
susceptibility so the evolution of that
that risk and really also ensures that
our knowledge is increasing over all the
time but if you think that the knowledge
is increasing kind of quest actively
because usually people would say hey
this is great we had 17 then we had 62
and then you had one of the 10 you guys
are fantastic the knowledge is really
grown
from from one verse entry to the legs
actually this is not exactly exactly
true and I'll show you why in that slide
so I can prick I cannot show you this
we're bringing this is essentially a
screen capture where what we show is
essentially the markers their risk and
in frequency and the effect size and
we'll show a larger larger circle here
in the epic size is greater so but we
gain more statistical significance here
so we're going up on average we
obviously anymore that would become
shown here is actually even the
description of a particular region is
changing so it's not necessarily ensure
that the genetic marker we use for me
for 10 jun 2010 will be the same in
2011-2012 or in 2013 so for genome-wide
Association studies it's not so much of
a problem because we usually obsessed by
p-value less the statistical
significance of the finding we certainly
go on to report a false positive so
we're very very cautious about
Commission region that we think are we
truly associated with earnest what what
marker we're going to use we don't care
so much and we don't loop select other
properties but if you start to use these
markers to describe an individual risk
you're doing something very different
you're not trying to find a statistical
correlation between MS and the presence
of our particular needs what you're
trying to do is we're trying to
categorize patients so it's use one
making 2010 with the frequency of ten
percent while ten percent on average ten
percent of your patients will be
learn more will be categorized as at
least four letter words map but it's
your changing snips in 2012 and you're
actually using a little bit more
frequent marker because a more frequent
marker gave you more statistical power
and since you select that by p value
what's going to happen is you're going
to really qualify patients that were not
at risk for the cembalotes rotors in
2010 now they're going to become a treat
for 2011 so what it children or it
suggests is that the linearity of the
number of snips and regions that we know
that our city with MS and that quantity
increase does not at all reflect the
complexity of the Association and the
fact that we change gear and may use
another a different name for the same
major again it's not a concern for
dealers because they're looking for a
great p values and statistical
significance but it's very important for
when Neutron actually to categorize
patients and find an individual way to
summarize the aggregation of genetic
risk allele at an individual level so
I'm not going to talk more about about
this msg and genetics are this plenty of
tables that have been published in
annals of neurology in 2017 college
three last year's looking at the
property that visit our new scores and
how important it is to be able to
summarize individual genetic burden so
you can look at newspapers in this story
can i want to talk about genetics for
little bit just to illustrate a trend
that is absolutely true
multiple sclerosis which is pretty to
another type of data for work fourth
crew vs we used to be able to handle a
limited amount of information 11 angel a
gene a few dozen of sleep marker that
describe the risk of an ass it's not
possible anymore and because we have one
intense it's not possible by the
quantity of flips but even more
importantly it's actually not possible
anymore because of the complexity of the
association even for that region before
changing the and there's the marker that
described at best the association with
an ass for changing the elements they
have different frequency that means we
can have a nightmare and if I go a
couple slides back right here it's
actually exactly what happened for hla
and we used to pull on the HLA allele H
like a double new tool because of the
serology there was a bit of time and
then it become your two because new
activities were were available and
became hid our system with serological
techniques and then hii typing adorned
with molecular techniques and if we can
make sure that the other 115 where the
commodity were looked at died by pcr and
now we're sequencing all the Achaeans of
genes english now we're really refining
the association so think about that
instru for genetics and it's true for
many other fields a lot of new data and
an exponentially greet our growing
complexity of the associations true very
true for hla with 20 years of history
and very true for the smith outside the
erection and now we're talking about 100
regions so that's kind of create the the
need for our
or for bio screen and where I'm sitting
here is actually a little preview of the
genetic area of the biomarker area of
our bio screen application where we are
making available the information about
genetics at the bench so we have
patients that have been tied for all
regimes this is version from 2012 so we
have 62 markers all the patients are at
I produce market and you provide a
graphical summary of what genes are
actually available but some of the right
panel in here so this is typically a
patient in explicit in for hiv-1 1501
and that should present a certain amount
of the knowledge the decrease 12.5
percent so we shall slice in the fruit
pie of known genetic risk that display
HLA and all the other small slices here
are actually other risk allele from
larger that different clothes I that are
also present in this particular patient
so if you want to summarize how much
this patient has in terms of genetics we
are working computer score that that
represent a weighted sum of the log of
ratios for each other this video it's
very difficult to interpret and I
actually don't think we should try to
interpret too much what we can do is
actually mean interpret this kind of
information by comparison to a group a
reference group which are here a healthy
controls so we stand on for a number
that we have this genetic risk or this
msg msg native burden that we have for
this one patient is really a score that
is difficult to interpret but what we're
doing here is verson hey compared to
about 500 healthy
draws what we can tell you is that only
two percent of the healthy controls have
such a high genetic risk or and so when
making in a personal interpretation of
the genetic risk or by comparison to a
reference group and that's pretty much
how the ms-dos wing stop and say hey if
we're doing that for genetics it doesn't
need to try to translate that and get
back from the genetic research project
we need to be regional how much what are
the genes are were the least le another
presence how much the spatially loaded
soon that's probably true for a little
other type of variable as well and
typically in this example between we
have a suspicion that these patient may
be pretty gently loaded compared to how
the patients in control so we realized
say you know what we're doing in
genetics is really having a lot of data
that we've been crushing crunching to
really understand unless genetics but
that's actually true for many other
dimension of the data and we are very
lucky to have this ms epic cohort which
really represent eight to ten years or
forward for about 600 patients which
about between 4,000 5,000 patient ear so
this is a lot of data it contains
clinical information memorized treatment
genetic and different type of genetic
and we want to address the idea to the
problem that these data is not rly union
right so many our clinicians and it's
not even really easy to use for
researchers and and
mirror people so we saw that maybe this
data set should be better better
accessible I've been dividual level and
let me show you yeah sorry I am to be
better accessible to really address this
idea that there's many to replica
actions and we want to accelerate the
path to finding the right treatment for
the right patient so again in a mess the
challenges are evaluate the disease how
see they are the recent years how fast
the patient is progressing challenge
number two is to select the right
treatment at the right time and because
it's so complex there's really an
opportunity to educate and better
communicate with the patient moving
reference data and and maybe it's also
sent least now to some extent for both
commissions and research to better
understand the data that we have so what
we really try to do say okay let's take
it and an individual patient let's force
yourself not to work with thousands of
patients as the distinction or
epidemiologist let's work like
clinicians which one patient but we
wanting it and integrate the information
about clinical data model function
genetic information and brain and I
imaging intervention spinal cord and in
all information of a treatment
environmental exposure and what we want
to do in is answer for the patient how
her particular not suppose to roses is
evolving how this one patient is is
progressing so down were pretty sure the
video which one she show you a couple of
example of how we're showing these
creams and how we're trying to do that
giving this ipad application that we
have for multiple sclerosis and switch
here for a minute will inverse
start in the media number video so this
is really an ipad application that i
have here on my ipad mini that's
connected to directly to the data to the
database we have in california in to
situate says and you really have all
this information make sure i'm gonna be
sucking on video now try good my desktop
sharing what i know okay the MS bios
screen is the first precision medicine
tool developed here at UCSF by a leading
team of scientists and researchers it is
designed to bring the latest research in
multiple sclerosis to the bedside take
an for example she is 31 years old and
was diagnosed with MS 10 years ago and
has been on aggressive therapy for
almost two years she has been using a
cane for walking and has had trouble
with spasticity and balance what n wants
to know is how her disease is likely to
progress how she compares to similar
patients and what course of action will
best treat her symptoms and slow down
the disease the MS bios screen brings a
new look into the disease in three ways
first during consultation dr. Smith can
access all of Ann's data and instantly
get a snapshot of how her disease has
been progressing over time second dr.
Smith can compare and to similar
patients to provide a frame of reference
that is tailored to Ann's
characteristics dr. Smith can also very
simply access other types of data from
this tool such as imaging thirdly the
enhanced comparison enables dr. Smith to
assess the probable path of Ann's
disease which informs a more precise and
personalized therapeutic decision making
the MS bios screen is also a great way
for dr. Smith to share information with
an so she can be equally informed of her
disease progression and actively
participate in her treatment decision
this is a new way to practice medicine
that is evidence-based data-driven and
highly personalized to accelerate the
path to the right treatment for each
patient
thank you very much so again so this is
really a prototype that we've been
looking at at UCSF it's it's a
functional prototype that we have
available for four or six hundred
research patients and the animation is
will need to be able to access right
here from from the ipad the data of any
of our patients you can see is near and
basically me connecting to the central
database getting access to the treatment
information into the clinical data to
metrics that will compete for you from
MRIs and genetic information so giving
the slides that I had in here I and the
the video is pretty quick I want to go
back on the main features of that so the
first thing is we aggregate all type of
patient data into single thing and
that's that's typically the only page
that we have in here and basically we
have all the basic information about the
patient and including the history of
will happen in the rhesus needles and
what treatment were you when there were
relapses and etc that's kind of a
patient overview and and kind of a
homepage we also want to get access to
information that is not typically easy
to access to and a very good example of
that it's which bag is 3d 4d our MRI
data it's also true for genetically
biomarker they're not usually available
to clinicians and two functions but
typically we want to solve this data
accessibility problem so we have images
for six years in a row for patient that
had an arrived we want to accept me in a
nation so we developed a proprietary
system where we have the MRI stored in
the cloud and through the Wi-Fi we pull
them down to our to the ipad and we can
see look at them nepalese 3d where you
can actually let move the slide they
miss rise in the cut in the brain space
it's also other time what you want to
actually see me how a region is
progressing for one particular patient
and more importantly when implemented
since the data is available for one
patient we implemented comparisons that
are tailored to the one patient we will
you clean characteristics so that sounds
are complicated but the best way to
understand what we're doing is to think
about pediatricians what pediatrician
are doing when they have kids and they
wait the kitten and the measure them and
essentially what vitamins and they they
they take you baby boy or you baby girl
the wave them and instead of telling you
hey doctor oh I think your daughter is
she's a little petite and kind of having
a subjective assessment well what are
they doing they're actually getting lost
girl and say hey so if i take the weight
of your daughter in that particular
growth chart that is improv and you know
young our baby america i can tell you
that your daughter is in the bottom two
percent so you really have to feel it so
that's really what we call they had
believed in evidence that's really what
you want to do is the bios screen by
omission access to and
and can of data so for that we developed
really a two-hand infrastructure a
back-end infrastructure that contains
all the information available from the
cloud and let's make that available to
the application and the application
really improve in the front hand of this
knowledge and data infrastructure where
we present all the data you have nice
overview again we're showing for one
fits probation what is the data that is
available then it's also secure and we
really developed a hipaa-compliant
infrastructure for all the names that
you are seeing now are actually fake we
use use market for all the PHR
information but security is taken very
seriously and when you look at a
particular metric and this is typically
DSS whether it's the most use chemical
functional disability scale for multiple
sclerosis you can actually see in blue
number one the individual trajectory of
a patient so what all the time what is
is trajectory over time to you can and
that's the bottom bar you can find and
the application proposed to the user
using an algorithm reference for
predation to be used to compare that
patient so basically patient with the
same disease duration and from these
references of patient we're computing
the orange background which provide a
normal each assessment under the search
feature that I want to stress on that
screen and the solid orange line
represents the median of the patient in
the reference group and and you also
have the two qualities the first and the
third quartile but sure you where most
of the other trajectories are and and so
you can see that Russia and I
showed that but essentially here we are
showing relapses and treatments as as a
VAR and again if you have the
infrastructure to that it's really up
it's happening lots of possibilities and
that's what i want to show here is what
we're doing here and that we can
actually show how one patient is
progressing and like actually some sort
of predictions how we do that it's
actually very simple you say hey let's
look at all the patients that were lying
this one patient two years ago a one
year ago and let's do that to actually
make a projection about what are the
most likely scenarios for that
particular patient in one year and you
can actually refine these computation
depending on the kind of drugs senior
you want to try to test you can do that
for drug a good b vaccine and actually
try to use this information to mine the
data in a personalized way to better
make a decision about that a treatment
that you want to propose to the patient
it also better to discuss what's the
actual therapeutic options and and the
pros and their combs with with the
patient so this is typically an example
of our screen that enable defining the
reference population so you can if you
want to compare a female patient to only
female patient that's something
absolutely doable you just have to
switch off the mail and we're going to
listen a request to a central database
to say hey oh great we have to use less
let's patients but you can recompute the
neurology assessment and this is
procedural for many many others type of
parameters including its duration in
this course asia onset and etc we should
leave the 3d serial magnetic resonance
brain imaging so we can choose freedom
the actual under images and in this
prototype we should be 92 total density
and and get aluminum our contrasting
images we can actually overlays and
information we shall hear a nap the
night in what attraction on the top of
the images so it's really about making
the data available 3d and eventually for
the dimension when you have several
exams at a time like you have six in
here so it is pretty much what I wanted
to tell you about this prototype and
where we are what we've been doing a new
clean truck we've been working in cycles
to get a prototype that's what we have
for now I usually call it like come to
the car it was a quick development we've
been working on that for the best 18
monsters and we conduct the two pilots
two sets of pilot study one inflation
and working with a mission to try to
better understand what we're doing and
where we should take it in ministering a
second pilot to better the rate how this
kind of tools will enhance practice and
change practice in the in the clinic so
there was a couple of bonuses supporting
these supporting at least this type of a
palace Ted and typically about the
patients we felt that this kind of
application how patient better
understand that easy means share the
data they want to share the data for
research and they also want to compare
the result to a location that was not
granted to we can ask them and we did
the same with physician we also thought
that that
that would really enable data driven
presentation of these features for
decision making because the data is all
here at hand you can provide tailored
comparison there are external and
eventually we give access to data that
are typically not so easy to get like
something like a computer from from
brain MRI is the annual change in brain
atrophies when the quanta styling what
is usually a qualitative assessment of
of being of the brain atrophy as seen by
the neuroradiologist anh anh vien right
images so there's a couple of questions
we have we have the patience but what I
wanted to do is actually before before
showing to you the results that we got
from patients I thought this webcast
tool is actually great and I wanted to
propose to you to answer the same
questions so if you don't mind let's do
it and the first question I wanted to
ask you is when you feel comfortable
obtaining your personal research data
even though it has not been approved for
diagnostic purposes because many time
that's the question that was raised
actually by the NRV hearing this project
was founded at the federal level say hey
you can't do that this is research data
and most of the time the consent
actually explicitly say we are not we
you won't get an individual return on on
your data we need to kind of reaction it
all of the episodes assumption saying
hey data is just data and if patients
want to access the data yeah we maybe we
should we should do it and how so we
have sexually the patients and we say
hey when you
you know you would you actually be okay
in looking at your data even if these
dates are like genetics has no impact on
critical information on clinical data
it's not clear certified you stand
approved for for for this kind of
application so this first question was
really about accessing research data and
you know that's that because what we
believe is that means kind of technology
like the bios screen is actually
blurring the frontier between where is
fda-approved in a way and what is not
FDA approval I will let you enter our
fourth leaving a few more fragance I
have about half of your wedding so the
question again is would you feel
comfortable obtaining your personal
research data even though it has not
been approved for diagnostic purposes
thank you very much after more minutes
Rowell thank you for your question you
were asking about a couple of more
answers going very quickly thank you
very much to all it's actually very
similar to what we have for the patient
i'm going to close it okay i want i'll
show you the result then and i'll tell
you what the patients were thinking
about but essentially we are about
ninety percent of yes okay thank you
very much
so the next question we have the
patience words actually to test whether
the fact that we're using a software
application was generate was actually a
problem for patient so we have then will
you be interested in using a secure
software application a website or a
tablet application like the one we
developed for ms-dos scream and in order
to access your research data and also
eventually the clinical data thank you
very much for answering the question and
it's remarkable we have a quarter of the
world of the attendance right now it's
remarkable clearly war from what our
patients are saying it's really pretty
interesting when you give another
minutes many other questions that we ask
too bad to the patients I had a question
from rel that patterns in healthy
controls it's actually right that we
find I suppose you're talking about
genetic genetic risk we do find a lot of
healthy control that have very very
similar risk pattern then then depending
on the patient and fortunately it's only
genetics we don't have a more
information on healthy control that will
enable us to find attorneys Americans or
many other metric that we have for
patients that that we can use to find
similarities between controls and
patients their soul or literature saying
that they found
within families get some patterns those
of genetics and other features between
the siblings of affected patients so the
other so we have them about the software
we also ask the patients okay so make
sure the question is there with two
questions doesn't matter i assume that i
don't have a inaudible to push all the
questions but essentially we have the
patient about on which they wanted to
have a comparison with other patient
there was question is really how much
they would be willing to enter or
provide their whole information question
for and and he's eventually they'd like
to see data information in working and
the other sets of questions were have
killed a signal generation of questions
that also question in a way so trying to
better understand why this is a
personalized application how
so we have them if there's more
information or this area that they don't
see in the data in particular we develop
new new features and new screens about
quality of life data but we had in mind
you know it's assume that patients will
take a more active part in the decision
making process if you want to query that
was question 2 and questions swinging
and maybe if you have lived more time at
the end out due to answer their
questions and really offering a question
in the forum what about to rapid excited
you right there and questioning if I was
about the fact that a lot of the
information is actually use algorithm
and computerized information so it's
pretty much the man versus machine or
some automated algorithm that that are
are getting an increasing role into this
date so just let me show you know some
of the level we got from from the
patients and it's remarkable that
ninety-six percent of the patient
actually feel very comfortable using
their having access to their research
data not about ninety percent feel
extreme fear also are interested by
accessing information using in a car
using an app or website they 92 93
person it's probably be clear seen in
the most recent of that of the patient's
actually want a comparison and we were
actually surprised by how high this
number yes we were expecting to leave
less than that and what we actually also
who is that that's in the ones that
don't want to see their comparison
it seems and again Tim we're talking
about 40 people here it seems that the
people that don't want to see a
comparison half of them are actually
patient who will win no they're not
doing so well so they don't want you see
themselves in the portion of fashion
that are not doing so well but there's
another about how the stations we just
don't care about all these data when
they care about is the trust they have
with their physician and say great
doctor you're using this tool it's
fantastic I'm sure you're making the
decision I'm sure you're making better
decision I feel fortunate that you're
using these kind of tools which are
investments and etc etc so it's really
an interesting concept you see that the
use of technology no way a reinforced
the trust between the physician and the
finishin lots of patience but these are
florist cohort are willing to enter
their own information we could think
about sending their MRIs think about
providing information by the quality of
life and you know night hunt of 10 we'd
also agreed to receive information
remotely and advice phone from the data
so we also have the clinician about to
better understand what they filled is
interested in this application solar
they're moving the application to shoot
the patients and essentially what it
shows is it's certainly the Sydney great
complement factor it's very convenient
to be able to access all this
information in one place it's certainly
help to empower physician maturity at
the point of care and are in particular
when they have access to to data that is
not typically available at in rural
clinics and it also has some may be some
potential predictive value that this is
probably not very
and again this is just that we've been
working on for 18 monsters but what is
also interesting is that they said that
it's starting to shift the their
traditional clinical reasoning from
using other edge rebels which are the
one that are published to individual to
find a really an individual normally
care system that is data driven I prefer
an interest of time algun our switch one
or two slides just watching insist on
the side that we know descriptive maybe
comparative to other patients but we're
not really protective and prescriptive
so far that's the start of the
application that's what we're working on
now I'll skip this one but we're working
very hard to integrate more data from
clinical trial and from electronic
medical records databases so we cannot
skip these two challenges because we had
our own cohort in database system and so
what we also have in here is winning
challenges to make the base cream
working on different kind of platforms
between different kind of mini marts
like a solution that will be plug on the
top of database using different kind of
data and so the bios screen is really
the power 3 now use the clinical
research data and making it actually
more usable than they typically are and
and promote US census of integration so
again within that application like the
ms-dos cream for complex chronic disease
really try to address the challenge of
the dynamic management of the disease
it's probably applicable to other
chronic conditions and in all the
blocking there were three key appreciate
failures to visualize the data to
contextualize it to understand data
using comparison and to be able to
interact where's the interpretation and
the way we do the leverage assessment of
the patient or two thanks again all the
people more than 50 people that have
been working with purse and over the
past eighteen nineties and I'll be happy
to answer more questions by an by email
and if you want to check our website
enabled online thank you very much for
your attention I'll take more questions
so I have a couple of gift question
sorry our outputs like just a few of
them I'll be very happy to fill up by
email I have a question about security
which is interesting and so the question
is you should have a house in the
patient didn't mean that yep the
application is really secure its and
yeah and you're referring to target that
lost or was was hacked for a credit card
information that that's very true i
think it's the problem is drawn here
there's the security about is somebody
will have access to information which is
different from the fact that many type
of different information are aggregated
into the same place genetics and our
eyes and etc etc so these are two
different questions that we don't know
how she had to set the rate because it's
not always very clear so we're wet
patient had in mind sometimes they think
about their clinical they are pretty
hard information because a hacker will
take money from their account different
from being anxious about having so much
information into the same place after
all no credit card information is I've
just only one account one back and but
it's not all your all your history
easily of the data and not your passing
your future and the present information
so if people have very important
questions at the end to answer that or a
tiebreaker on one aspect or the other of
the biosphere so I also have a question
about context organization I can't close
our I'll be happy to follow up on
questions about algorithms and ride
visualization technologies and
applications where the disease is also
very important questions yes if me it
has the potential to be applied to many
other disease and well-being a happy to
what our next step is to try to deploy
that into different centers nothing yet
it yourself to be able to aggregate more
data and strengthen the power of the
algorithm to be out making predicted so
thank you very much for your attention
is maybe frustrating not to see the
audience but I hope put me in touch our
nature on my butt you know thank you
very much for your tantrum and I soap
will have opportunities to meet you
it's seven it's 705 p.m. here in the
northwest of France I'll be back to us
very soon thank you very much